Here, x would equal 4 3rds. Nice thinking if you got this number. Now, if this
gave you some trouble, that's okay. We haven't had a lot of practice rewriting
numbers with different bases, so let's see how it works. I know that both 27
and 81 are the result of raising 3 to a certain power. For example, 3 cubed is
27 and 3 to the fourth is 81. Notice too that now I have the same base. I have
a 3 here, and a 3 here. But before I do anything, let's combine these two
exponents. When we raise a power to a power, you multiply these two together.
This is how we get 3 to the 3x equals 3 to the fourth power. Now, since these
two bases match, we set these exponents equal to one another. So we'll have 3x
set equal to 4 here, and then we'll divide both sides by 3 to get x equals 4
3rds. And if you check this in a calculator or by hand, you'll definitely see
that 27 raised to the 4 3rds equals 81. We know this is true since the cube
root of 27 equals 3. And 3 to the fourth power is 81. So yes, our answer checks
and we can be sure that it's correct.